There's an episode where there's a Comic-Con
and while two attendees are fighting over
a $2,000 Tardis replica, one of
them has his ears ripped off and
has to have it sewn back on.
Is the episode called Dr. Huh?
So, Tom, I know you are a big fan of Grey's
Anatomy. And by I know you are a big fan, I mean
to say you are not a fan at all of Grey's Anatomy.
Stop it, man. Huge fan of Grey's Anatomy.
I had it specially written on the back
of my driver's license that if anything
ever happens to me, I want to go to
Grey's Anatomy hospital and no other.
That's definitely what it's called.
Mm-hmm
That's the name of the hospital.
Prove me wrong. It's impossible.
Seattle Grace.
Who wants to sing the theme song right now. Brian?
I'm not doing it.
Nina?
I know it. I'm not doing it. You can't
trick me into singing on this show.
I assume that's how it goes.
Oh, no. No.
You guys are crushing it.
No, not that song.
Katherine Heigl.
Ellen Pompeo.
Yeah.
I love Grey's Anatomy you guys.
Okay, so.
I don't love Grey's Anatomy.
You've definitely watched it, I can tell.
What's your pick for the most over the top moment?
It's hard to say Brian, isn't
it? I mean with what, 17,
18 seasons? I couldn't pick just one,
but if I had to I'd probably go with
episode 18 of season seven, the "Song Beneath
the Song", the musical episode in which-
Oh, no. Why'd you bring that
up? I hate that so much.
What are you talking about?
What was wrong with that one?
I hate that episode. Go ahead, Tom.
It's a terrific episode.
No it isn't. Go on Tom.
Doctor... One of the doctors, whose name I don't
remember very well, she gets into a car accident.
Callie Torres.
It's deeply implied that it happens
because she's singing at the
time. Although that probably might be a-
That's not...
There's a lot of dream sequence stuff going on in
the episode, Callie Torres, Dr. Callie Torres...
She's the doctor, right?
Yes.
All right, sure. So she gets into a car accident
and as a result, everybody sings affordable but
recognizable songs from the pop top 500 chart.
No, actually it gets worse. They sing songs
that were featured on the show
specifically in previous seasons.
Is that what's going on?
Yeah. Yeah.
Is there meaning behind that? Because...
It's literally just songs they've
played before. It sucks. I hate it.
Because it felt a little late. I kept-
No, because it's like
Chasing Cars, How to Save a Life,
the hits from Grey's Anatomy.
Those are the hits from-
I actually like the show. And
now I look like the most negative person about
it. I hate this episode. It's bad. It's so-
From Scrubs. I thought they
were just playing Scrubs music.
No, because the Scrub... Well, that was the thing,
is Scrubs hired Robert Lopez and Kristen Anderson
Lopez to write, they're the people who did
Avenue Q, to write the Scrubs musical which
is why it's good.
Got you.
And then for this one, they were like, "Make
Tony award-winner Sarah Ramirez sing covers of
songs by The Fray. This is our whole idea."
And the songs all seem like they're either
super on the nose, like...
Or unrelated. Yeah.
They have an argument about how to operate
on somebody so they play How We Operate.
Mm-hmm. Yeah.
Or they're making fun of the trauma
victim because they do play Chasing Cars after
this woman gets into a horrendous car accident.
And she's as she's bleeding she's singing
about like, "I don't need anyone" as doctors
are just huddled around her, trying to
save her life. So I didn't particularly
understand. But that wasn't actually my pick.
My pick was for the next episode, episode 145
of Grey's Anatomy which is called "It's
a Long Way Back." Because at the end
of the singing episode, there's a scene where a
premature rubber baby gets pulled out of somebody
and you're not sure if it's going to live or
not. I thought they were going to bump it off.
I thought they were going to be rubber baby buggy
bumpers, but they didn't. The baby survives.
And then at the beginning of the
next episode, you get to see it in
the NICU. And I actually did bring a... I
brought a visual element. I just want you
guys to check it out.
I knew it.
The most over the top part of it for me. The
most over top moment on Grey's Anatomy was
when they dressed up this premature baby
as Captain Cold from The Flash comics.
Oh, no.
Oof, Tom. Thomas.
It's rubber.
Yeah, it is.
No.
They made it out of marzipan. Don't be mad at me.
It's not edible.
You say that.
I mean, anything is edible
if you have enough time.
If you try hard enough, yeah.
Thank you, Brian.
For the viewers not paying attention,
Brian just said it's possible to eat that
baby. I'm sorry. So whose turn is it now?
I'll go. So Grey's Anatomy is a show that I've
watched a few times with a woman I used to date
many years ago. And as a result, it always kind of
stuck in my mind as a show that I kind of watched
begrudgingly. And just today, looking these
moments up to try to find something to talk about
I was struck by how entirely watchable it actually
is. And I was like, "Oh wow. Maybe I should watch
Grey's Anatomy again." So I'll just throw that
out there. It's pretty good. It's well done. So
the one I picked was an episode called Shiny Happy
People. And it guest stars Demi Lovato, as a girl
who tries to claw her own eyes out because
her parents think that she is schizophrenic.
And as it turns out, and I was hoping it was
going to be wackier than it was and it wasn't.
It wasn't. It was hardly wacky at all.
There wasn't a zany punchline to this?
No, there wasn't... I thought it was going
to be a lot nuttier because as it turns out,
she can hear her internal organs
and that's what's making her go kind of-
And they're all telling her to kill Gerald Ford.
If you don't mind me asking, and I'm sorry
to interrupt. Brian, what was your idea for
a wacky ending to this episode? What was-
Not that I thought it was going to be wacky,
I thought it was going to be really, really
over the top. I thought it was going to be
really overreacted. I thought it was going to
be extremely melodramatic. I thought that they
were going to kind of biff the diagnosis and I
looked it up and it's a totally real diagnosis.
Oh, it is?
It's called... Yeah. Superior Canal
Dehiscence Syndrome, I think it's called. Yeah.
I always get the sense that while they probably do
say the names of actual conditions on
Grey's Anatomy, I've never once thought that
people actually show up in the ER with a pole
between two of them holding them together
that often. So I'm like, when I saw that episode
I was like, "Okay, maybe someone has that but it's
probably not presented in this way." Right? Where
they're like, "I'm clawing my face off." Yeah.
I looked it up and I was like,
"They got to be making this up."
Yeah.
But, I'll say this.
The show exaggerates the symptoms apparently
because... This woman played by Demi Lovato,
everyone thinks that she's mentally ill because
she's hearing things and everything's too loud,
nothing makes sense. And then at the end, Dr. Alex
is just like, "She can hear her internal organs."
Right.
And I read
that and I was like, "Well, that's got
to be crazy." And then I looked it up
and apparently you can hear... The internal
sounds you can hear very loudly because of a
thinning or a hole in a membrane in your ear.
That sounds awful.
But one of the things that apparently is true
is that you can hear your eyeballs moving
if you have this condition. So, I was like,
"All right. Good restraint, Grey's Anatomy.
You took this absolutely terrifying thing
and made it actually seem realistic."
Right. Wow.
So the only thing for me that struck me as
quite over the top in this particular episode were
two things. One, a bunch of doctors sitting around
watching this poor woman get a CAT scan. And
they're like, "I think she's just crazy. I don't
know." And they're like, "Yeah, she's crazy."
And then Dr. Alex is like, "I know crazy. I dated
crazy. My dad was crazy. She's not crazy." And
I'm just kind of like, "You're all doctors, you're
throwing the word crazy around very liberally."
Yeah.
It's okay for me, and uneducated YouTube guy to
say it casually when referring to an episode of
television, but you're actually medical doctors.
I would not call them all good doctors.
Right.
They're not all good doctors. Yeah.
So the other thing I noticed when I looked
it up, the main doctor who said crazy a lot
of times is a character named, this was the
nuttiest thing for me, Dr. Arizona Robbins.
Yes.
That's not a real name.
That's the silliest name I've ever heard.
She is played by Jessica Capshaw,
whose mother Kate Capshaw is Spielberg's
wife and was in Indiana Jones. Yeah.
That's right.
That's her daughter. Yeah.
Very good.
Child of Willy.
Willy.
Yeah.
It all comes together full circle.
Mm-hmm.
Is that why they named her Arizona? Because the
Indiana...
Ooh.
God, I hope so. There's a really
convoluted explanation in the show.
Well that would make sense.
But now it better be.
Now I like it. Because you don't name someone
Arizona... Okay. All right. You know what?
I take it all back. Best show ever.
See?
Nothing.
Yeah.
I have nothing. All right.
So anyway. Nina, you know about Grey's Anatomy.
I do.
You've watched Grey's Anatomy.
A lot of times.
What is the most over
the top moment from Grey's Anatomy that
you would like to share with us today?
There's so many good ones. I mean, I mentioned
the people stuck on the pole. We've talked
previously about the bomb in the body cavity. There
is a whole subplot where Katherine Heigl,
in order to get Jeffrey Dean Morgan a new heart,
cuts his LVAD wire and basically leaves him
hanging on the precipice of death so he can get a
heart transplant. And then they just let her work
at the hospital anyway. It feels like maybe she
should go to prison for that, but what do I know?
There's a kid who gets encased in concrete
because he's trying to impress a girl.
So, there he's stuck in concrete.
We've all been there.
Yeah. Yeah. We've all
definitely lived through that.
In Katherine Heigl's defense, Jeffrey
Dean Morgan did come back to life as
a ghost and then had sex with her a bunch.
He did. And I would say that also ranks among
craziest moments. There's the mass shooting
episode, which I actually maintain is like...
And it's the highest ranked on IMDB for a reason.
I do think it is the best two part episode of
the show. But it's also really... I mean, it's
also like the shooter is played by the friendly
secret service agent from West Wing, Agent
Butterfield. So you're just like, "No, I
trusted you. You protected the president." There's
an episode where there's a Comic-Con and while two
attendees are fighting over a $2,000 TARDIS
replica, one of them has his ears ripped off
and has to have it sewn back on.
Is the episode called "Dr. Huh?"
I was going to say, "Dr. What?"
"Dr. What?" There's an episode where
a guy saws his foot off because it's
hurting and he just wants it to be
off. There's an episode where a lion...
Literally my favorite John Woo movie.
There's an episode where a woman has
a pet lion and it roams around Seattle
mauling people, including her boyfriend.
None of these are your pick for
most over the top, by the way.
No.
We haven't gotten
to your pick yet. Okay.
No, I mean... For me,
it's like a little bit of a... I think over
the top probably had to be the lion because...
Where is the top? Let's find the top first.
Oh, thank god. Because unless you're going to
beat Lyle, Lyle, Crocodile, but like the R rated
e-book, because that's what this sounds like it
is. Okay. What's better than lion in Seattle?
Well, this is a personal choice because it was
just such a good twist. So at the end of season
one, Ellen Pompeo's character, Meredith has been
dating Patrick Dempsey's character, Derek for
the entire season. And aside from the fact that
he's her boss and it's a massive HR violation,
it's going pretty well. And they're in the lobby
of the hospital and this beautiful glamorous
woman walks in and she's like, "Oh, I'm Addison
Shepherd. You must be the woman sleeping
with my husband." And then the season ends.
Whoa.
So he's been married the whole time.
Whoa, what a cliffhanger.
And including the audience also does not know, but
it's perfect melodrama. It's super over... That's
how she opens the conversation? It's ridiculous.
I love every second of it. It's so stupid.
What if she had been wrong?
Right.
What if it was a different doctor?
What if that had just been a nurse giving him
some files or some paperwork or something?
Yeah.
Right.
What if right after that
she gets mauled by a lion?
How many people did she approach before she
got to Meredith Grey? It's, "Oh, hello."
Oh, yeah. "So it must be you."
She gets into the taxi at the
airport and she's like, "Hello, you
must be the woman that's been..."
Oh man, am I just...
Oh. Yeah. No. I mean, this is
something I appreciate about Grey's Anatomy,
is it knows exactly what kind of show it is.
Yeah.
It's ridiculous heightened camp, and I love it.
I mean, is the lion more over the top
objectively? Yes. Is the Addison Shepherd
entrance an all time high of the show?
Also yes. So my answer contains multitudes.
Was he separated or something? Does it matter?
Basically, yeah. She had cheated on him with his
best friend and he just kind of left New York.
Oh, she started it.
She started it.
Yeah. She started it. This is how mature adults...
The classic defense in divorce court.
"Your honor, she started it."
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. I love the show.
That's how my dad got custody.
I love this weird dumb show.
Yeah, no it makes sense. Yeah.
Shonda Rhimes, if you're watching this,
I am the sole defender of the show.
Please ignore these other two.
I think it's fine. I think it's fine. I'll
probably watch it someday in its entirety.
Yeah.
I respect Brian.
Yeah. It seems good. It seems like a good show.
Tom, not everything is for you. And I know
as a white dude that must be
baffling, but not everything is.
It's hard to hear. It's hard to hear.
I've never had to put up with this before.
Thanks for watching. Please hit like and
subscribe so you don't miss a single episode.